Khloe Kardashian enjoys a Mexican  getaway with NBA pro Tristan Thompson  I'm having so much fun the rumored  couples yet it's south of the border to  Cabo San Lucas to have some fun under  the Sun here's Chloe on Monday looking  bootylicious in a cutout red one-piece  the 25 year old Cleveland Cavalier star  joined the 32 year old reality star out  at sea where they wrote jet skis  together and Tristan was snap smiling  ear-to-ear I just want to live my life  and be happy but Tristan isn't the first  basketball star Chloe's been linked to  she was previously married to Lamar Odom  and dated genes hardened before calling  it quits in February  earlier this year Chloe opened up to et  about her love life I'm someone who I do  like to put my relationships as a  priority and I tried to make I really  try to make that work right um and as  long as people are making the effort to  do so I think anything can work